OK, next question today, David. Can Democrats
add Puerto Rico in Washington, D.C., a states
without Republican involvement? So there's
two answers to this. Legally speaking,
constitutionally speaking, admitting a
new state is not a legislative matter.
So the legislative filibuster that is possible
in the Senate on some issues should not actually
apply. And as the week recently published in
recent years, both Democrats and Republicans
have in effect agreed the filibuster shouldn't
apply to certain constitutional matters not
covered by Article one, which lays out the
design of Congress and its legislative powers.
The admission of new states is not part of Article
one, and it's something distinct. And as a result,
in theory, Democrats don't need Republicans to
make Washington, D.C. or Puerto Rico states. Now,
historically, this is a different matter.
The idea from the framers appears to be they
clearly designated the addition of states as not
requiring a super majority. But at the same time,
it is not particularly likely that
from a practical political standpoint,
Democrats would go it completely alone. And
from the people I've spoken to that are aides
to elected officials, there is the belief that
it is, if it is not bipartisan to some degree,
that it would be unlikely to happen. And so,
although from a very fundamental legal standpoint,
Democrats could say we are voting to make
D.C. a state and it could be 50/50 in the
Senate and then Kamala Harris could cast the
deciding vote. That certainly could be done.
I have not spoken to anyone who thinks that
it's going to actually be done that way and
that more than likely, if Democrats were dead
set on making D.C. and or Puerto Rico states,
even if Republicans weren't thrilled with it,
that there would be some kind of negotiation
where Republicans would get something. Now,
what that something is, I don't actually know.
One other thought on this. I don't know
for sure that every Democrat in the Senate,
in the absence of some Republicans who want to
make D.C. and or Puerto Rico states, I don't
know that every Democratic senator would actually
go for it. So there's actually a question as to
whether you get to 50/50 with Joe Manchin vote
to make Puerto Rico and D.C. and or DC states,
if not a single Republican in the Senate
plans to do it. I don't know the answer
to that. And there is the feeling that there
are at least one or two Democratic senators
who, without some Republican
support for the additional states,
would not go for it. The real question to me is,
are we ever going to find out the answer to this?
Is this actually going to be something Democrats
try to do in the next two years as they control
the White House, the House and the Senate? I wish
I could say yes. It's not completely clear to me.